uh no
there we go
there's a job title on tatooine master
squeakums and that person's job is to
climb up and lube these whirly giggers
that person's currently doing a terrible
job which is why the whirly gigger
council is currently attempting to rally
a political rival to rise in the ranks
of the maintenance guild and usurp
master squeekums this by the way is a
much more interesting plot than whatever
boba fett is trying to do it's all there
we'll leave the spice and take the
credits back to me
do you know where you are gentlemen
arrakis they get through they shouldn't
have to think about it too much there's
three of them and one of him i mean i
know justified over there could probably
take out all four of the pikes before
they could get a shot off but they don't
know that now load that chest and go
considered a fine for trespassing
stealing we all wanted to see the gun
shoot and run tootin feller flip his
weapon into his holster but is now the
best time the enemy isn't gone and you
just lost any advantage of having your
gun drawn and ready to shoot the pattern
on this shirt was born from boredom a
ruler and a sharp set of spurs tell me
i'm wrong this spice is precious and
illegal so why put it in a box that can
easily be flipped open with the toe of a
boot i see we're still on a mandalorian
side quest and yes i've heard the fan
excuses of this is a mandalorian
spin-off and blah blah blah but here's
the thing even if that is the case i
don't recall an episode of star trek
deep space nine where we spent an
episode and a half with the tng crew and
never saw a single cast member from ds9
and if you want to argue that ds9 isn't
a spin-off of tng then i'll just say i
don't recall an episode of frasier where
we spent an entire episode and a half
with a gang of cheers without a single
frasier cast member in sight i've got
all day and a useless amount of spin-off
tv knowledge do you it's nice to see
that even with these mandalorian assigns
the show hasn't forgotten its main focus
countless scenes of characters walking
anyone alive we've been watching these
ant droids build a dome for a solid two
minutes no none of the audience is alive
anymore oh look groga is distracted by a
frog cliche new cliches are so cute when
they're young
[Music]
is this show also the issue with this
moment is that skywalker is trying to
save focus and i will teach you how to
use more power but the message grogu
receives is very likely more power
equals frog buffet i want to tell you
about someone you remind me of a great
deal
his name was yoda
he was small like you he was also the
same [ __ ] species but for some reason
creepy looking young luke is leaving
that little factoid out why creepy luke
why look appears to be moving grogu
forward so that he can keep up the
walking pace isn't that a bit of a dick
move let the kid walk in his own way why
force him to move forward because you
aren't willing to slow down force you
luke i mean it funny size matters not
luke quoting yoda quoting my ex-college
girlfriend feels really strange in this
show do you remember back home i don't
know the exact amount of time grogu's
been hanging out with luke but it's
definitely been long enough to where i'm
not buying this is the first time luke
has asked this question the galaxy is a
dangerous place grogu especially when
your name's grogu there's no kid that
could live that name down you
i didn't expect to see you here i didn't
expect to see any of you here but here
we are on the boba fett and friends
variety hour then what are you doing
here fan service duh there's nothing now
but will someday be a great school and
by some day they mean later in this
episode we're not sure exactly how much
time has passed because unlike other
sci-fi shows they're giving us zero
stardate indications
mando is a dick to grogu
really
that's all you got shaming a child for
jumping like a child come on i want to
show you something i mean sure interrupt
the kids attempted for sleeping and
spend the next few minutes showing off
your own abilities i'm here at the
request of fennec shand and that's all
you need to know to trust my intention
implicitly sure there's a war about to
break out and the card was clearly
concerned with my arrival but that's
okay as long as you know that i know
fenix name we're all good bone-headed
hood ornaments
we now interrupt this episode of jedi
training academy interrupting this
episode of the mandalorian interrupting
this episode of boba fett for an episode
of cobb vance space marshall
where's the little guy
back with his own folk
that's too bad
i guess we both lost something we were
fond of comparing the loss of body armor
to the loss of as close to his son as
amanda will probably ever have holy sh
this episode also has a mandalorian
walks into a bar cliche we're playing
all the hits today i love the idea that
these bones are from the dragon that was
slain but how long ago was that did the
whole town pitch together to pick all
the meat from the bone did they leave it
in the desert long enough for it not to
reek i'm sorry i didn't catch your name
i will give every sin back on my entire
channel if this guy says twinkleberry
blue howdy howdy howdy i mean why wear
bullets around your ankles that seems
like a very dangerous place that would
be jarred and bumped often not to
mention it's the furthest distance from
the gun you'd need to reload it's pretty
annoying that the first resemblance of
what i would consider to be a great
scene in this series takes place with
less than 10 minutes left in the
penultimate episode of the season and
because this is just going to be a
record that keeps on repeating it
doesn't include boba fett
fat i guess everyone wants to make sure
cobb is all right which makes sense but
they skip right over the deputy who is
well dead but do they know that can we
take your helmets for a cleaning i think
of all the characters in this series
these are the two i feel the worst for
they have one [ __ ] job and no one
will let them do it let them clean your
helmets but wait you forgot your cap so
star wars is just the godfather now
really looking forward to boba waking up
with a bantha head in his bed i guess
it's kind of nice we're not just ripping
off kurosawa anymore
omg that body armor is just i can't
resist it any longer remove a sin now
before i change my mind but you may
choose only one luke skywalker is the
party pooper of the star wars universe
which do you choose frogs he chooses
frogs
oh
nice shooting tex
do you know where you are gentlemen
i'll kill four of you before you even
clear your weapons i can see you're the
smart one i tried to imagine a fellow
smarter than myself and then i tried to
think what would he do i'm looking for
skywalker take me to your leader i
didn't expect to see you here nobody is
ready for oscar
and who might you be when a man with a
45 meets a man with a rifle you said the
man with a pistol is a dead man let's
see if that's true
you tell them i'm coming and hell's
coming with me you hear
my car
extreme
tell your master this the armies of
mordor must disband he is to depart
these lands never to return oh
old graveyard
i have a token i was bitten to show thee